what is that a bunny outfit oh my
goodness what is that
you don't like the bunny outfit i do
like it what does it signify people take
me seriously now
i should wear a full-length bunny outfit
so we're gonna do an old sword first are
you ready to do this we've never played
it like acoustic with the four of us
i want you to do this song like it's the
first time you ever did it yeah
all right first time i guess we've never
played this on the show because we never
play it this way we have no idea
i will tell you this we had all the
intentions in the world of rehearsing
this
and you didn't all right so do some
round here i'll sit back and judge it
go ahead and i'll tell you if you did a
good job afterwards 9.5
all right get ready for judgment if we
can't stack up and play this here we go
[Music]
it's about the front door like it goes
to the farm
no one notices
[Music]
between wrong and right well
[Music]
maria says she's dying through the door
i hear her
[Music]
we always stand up straight
[Music]
[Music]
maria came from nashville with a
suitcase in her hands she said she'd
like to meet a bar
who looks like elvis she walks along the
edge of where the ocean meets the land
just
like she is walking on a while
in the circus and she parks her car
outside of my house
and takes all her clothes off and says
she's close to understanding
she knows she's more than just a little
misunderstood
she has trouble acting normal when she's
nervous around here
we are carving out
our names
[Music]
sacrificed by
[Music]
oh
[Music]
little baby better get
[Music]
in my head
[Music]
did you think that you were dreaming
and i said no i didn't think that i was
dreaming and i said so
i just want it to come true
and baby all i need is you
she said did you think that you were
dreaming
i said no she said well did you think
that you were
[Music]
but i was out on
the radio just starting to change
somewhere out in america it's
starting to rain so could you tell me
one thing you remember
about me
or could you tell me one thing
[Music]
could you tell me one thing
could you tell me one thing
[Music]
that you will remember about me
there's a girl on a car in the parking
lot says man you should try to take a
shot
can't you see my walls are crumbling
and she looks at the bell and she says
hey
i'm thinking of jumping she said she's
tired alive while
everybody's trying to stop me
she's always on my mind
round here hey man
you know i've got a lot of time
[Music]
we stay up very
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just starting to change somewhere out in
america
it's starting to rain could you tell me
one thing you'll remember about me
did you think that you
i were no i did not think that i was
dreaming and i said so
i just want it to come true
and baby all i
all need need is all i
need is you well she said did you think
that you were dreaming i said
no i didn't think that i was dreaming
and i said so i just want it to come
true and
all i need is
you
wow i i gotta say that's i've had a lot
of bands come in here that was one of
the best performances